[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jeff pearlman has
written the book new york times
bestselling author of nine books host of
the
two writers slinging yang podcast
showtime magic kareem riley in the
lakers dynasty of the 1980s and now
hbo making it into a series
jeff good morning um how surprised were
you that you hear from me how did you
hear
from somebody who decided that this
would make for a great series
so there's a guy named jim hecht he's a
he's a writer and i only knew him
because i looked at his imdb
page and he was the writer of ice age
the meltdown
that was his main credit and he wanted
to come to my house and and sort of talk
to me about the idea of turning
this laker book into it he's like i just
think it could be something
and he shows up at our house this is
when we lived in new york in new
rochelle new york and he shows up
with a block of chocolate a tomato
and a bottle of fake wine like that was
his his wooing material that he brought
it was
i think he was at grand central and just
needed to bring something
he shows up at our house he's like i
just really think this could be
something good and i don't know and
we're like all right yeah yeah yeah
because
if you do this long enough you do get
stuff optioned and it almost never
becomes anything
i've had stuff options many times by now
and it never becomes anything
and here's this guy i say he's the
meltdown jim hecton you think this is
going to be nothing
and that was probably seven years ago
and now
i i don't know how this happened i swear
to god i have no idea how this happened
it's the craziest thing that's ever
happened in my career what's the status
of the production
they're starting uh to start in the film
and they did the pilot already
and they're starting to film multiple
episodes in a couple of days actually
and it's fully cast and it's
unbelievable
a lot of times we look at a sports movie
we think it's a sports movie but it's
about relationships
and i don't know if it's different in a
series because
you know how much of this is about
actual basketball or the relationships
within the basketball team or you know
jerry buss or pat riley so can you give
us a sense of what you think the
direction is
of showtime well i think they're they're
very hyper
into the sort of development of the
dynasty at least at this point
and sort of not just jerry bus but how
he became jerry buss
and um you know the the the
blooming of magic johnson um one thing
they've done that i i think is really
cool is
if you look at the cast they've combined
a lot of really established actors
playing these big roles um you know
adrian brody sally fields is different
and then like the guy playing magic
who's awesome this guy named quincy
isaiah
is just a young sort of unknown actor
and
it just seems like they're really
emphasize the blooming of relationships
and the development of these characters
not just
it's not just going to be a stupid you
know uh look at them play basketball
i'm just going to throw a bunch of balls
out there and have actors play
basketball really poorly
and things can be more about the
development of the characters which is
what you tried to do in a book
how do you cast kareem abdul-jabbar you
get someone very tall
the guy playing him was a play
basketball cow so um
they cast it very tall i mean i don't
you know it's it's interesting because
i've learned a lot
um about sort of what goes into it and
how
it's not just about height like you
don't just want a seven foot two guy
if all the other actors are five foot
eleven so everything isn't ratio and
everything is relative
um i actually learned a lot just from
observing and
sort of being kept in the loop about
everything and how it goes down
what's the one thing that you took away
from your book that you didn't know
like it became a lot larger or
it stayed quieter than you thought it
was going to
i actually at the time i was unaware of
the sort of demons of jerry west
i always saw growing up and then
watching basketball that jerry west was
just
calm cool collected and then you
you really get to know him and learn
about him and he's a really tortured
individual
it's kind of what makes him great but
the the everything he's gone through in
his boyhood
uh sort of abuse that the he
reminds me a lot of billy bean you
probably experienced a lot of billy bean
the kind of the
where he can't watch a game yeah i
remember covering the a's and billy
being could not watch a game
and jerry west is basically billy bean i
always found that torture really
interesting
yeah he's brought that up a couple times
that you know he had a shotgun under his
mattress and he was going to kill his
dad
who was abusing his mom and he said he
used to drive around like he couldn't
even be in the building sometimes with
the lakers with these big games
that he would drive around uh and then
wait till the game was over so just
one thing that's interesting you
mentioned in the intro of norm nixon and
matthew johnson the trading of norm
nixon
and um magic johnson was thrilled when
norm nixon was traded he was not upset
um oh there was a real conflict between
those two
uh norm nixon had been the established
point guard
and really viewed as his team and then
magic comes along and they kind of hand
it to him and it's his team
and there was no way it was going to
work having those two point guards it's
not like they hated each other
but there's not a very good encore
basketball relationship how tough was
riley
on these players i mean
it's interesting he came in and when he
arrived
he was a he was a completely
inexperienced
you know been a radio guy you know i've
been with chick hearn and then he uh
he's an assistant under west head and
suddenly he's he's a head coach
and everyone's like oh it's pat riley
laid back pat riley
and over the years he developed this
term called peripheral
distractions that was his thing we can't
have any peripheral distractions and
peripheral distractions
meant the media it met wives it meant
girlfriends
it meant anything that took away from
the team at all
and he became sort of hyper intense
about it and by the time he was done by
the time his run ended
uh the laker players wanted nothing to
do with him because he just had gone way
over the top
but if you i remember when wright
thompson did a profile on pat riley
and then you got an idea because when
wright does a deep dive
you're going to find out about that
person and you realize
that's pat riley you know perfectionist
never happy
uh you know what he grew up with it with
his father
and you know i would hear stories but i
was never close enough that
they just they kind of tolerated him you
know
at the end they sort of just tolerated
riles and but
he had definitely worn out his welcome
what's part of the book that
you might um be not
nervous about but you know maybe how do
you capture this
in in the true uh sense of what it
really was in the book
so there's um my favorite moment of all
the stuff i wrote about for that book
is um magic johnson's arrival in los
angeles and
there's this moment um that i just love
he comes to la for the first time to
negotiate with the lakers
and he's being driven in a limo down
some street
and he sees oranges growing on a tree
and he tells the guy to stop the car
and he gets out and he picks an orange
because he's just blown away by this
idea that i'm in this land where fruit
is growing on a tree
and i just think the essence of that
team and that era and everything about
in
that book can be summed up in magic
johnson picking an orange from a tree
and just i don't know how i'm not saying
you can't do it how you capture
the sort of late 70s early 80s
guy who's never been to california his
life about to change forever
all embodied by the beauty of an orange
on a tree
and just being dazzled by that fruit
sitting there i love that i don't know
if
i don't know how you capture that i just
think it's the most beautiful thing was
there
one move that almost didn't happen or
or the other way like they made a move
and and it
benefited them well the trade that
almost happened
that almost um ended the jerry buss
jerry west marriage
was uh they almost traded james worthy
to dallas for mark aguirre
and jerry buss agreed to the deal with
don carter the mavs owner
um behind jerry west's back and goes and
says to jerry west oh we have this deal
worked out
and on paper that's a complete that's a
very very fantasy basketball
kind of trade we're like this is amazing
mark mcguire averages 25 a game
and then you're stuck with mark aguirre
and jerry west said if you make this
trade i'm done here
so that trade i think almost ruined
everything did they almost not get magic
or pass on magic
well they um the first choice of of
jerry west he's loathed to talk about
this is a was sidney moncrieff
out of out of arkansas it's actually an
interesting thing though i i always say
this i mean hall of famer
if they if their back court is sidney
moncrief norm nixon with kareem at
center jamal wilks at one
that's not a bad team it's not it's not
the showtime lakers
but they're still probably they're
certainly in the in the topic of a kind
of a championship
but you know encrypt did not have the
charisma and the spark one that razzle
dazzle for magic johnson
but it was it was definitely considered
strongly but also the style that they
played jeff
that it was showtime was riley a fan of
showtime
yeah well you know the thing that's
interesting is it started their first
coach
was a guy named jack mckinney he was a
code people forget about this
the first coach actually um jerry
tarkanian was supposed to be the coach
and he jerry bus hired jerry tarkin they
agreed to it and then
and then jerry tarkanian's agent turned
up dead in the trunk of a car
and that tarkanian decided not to take
the job it's your story
then the hard drive wait is there is
there a back story on that jeff that
sounds like
a movie yeah well there are a lot of
there were a lot of mafioso ties
and i forgot exactly what the agent had
done
but he did he crossed some line you
weren't supposed to cross and they end
up being killed
and this was a close friend of tarkanian
and tarkanian decided he couldn't take
the job
there's too much going on blah blah blah
blah but then they hired jack mckinney
who had been
a longtime saint joe's assistant a head
coach
uh jack ramsey's assistant in portland
he's the head coach and
everything's going great and he puts in
this system that became known as
showtime
and i think it was 14 games or 11 games
into his first season
it's a day off he has one assistant
coach in the quaint days of the nba
uh paul westhead they're going to play
tennis
jack mckinney is riding his bike to meet
paul westhead
falls head head over heels um lands on
his head
it's amazing how this was so quaint of
the daisy he was a john doe in the
hospital the head coach of lakers
john doe in the hospital um has suffered
severe brain trauma paul west that takes
over
runs jack mckinney's system leads the
lakers to the championship
mckinney has never brought back westside
wears out his welcome quick
and riley comes in so riley just kind of
resumed the system called i mean he
started they started calling it showtime
but it really was jack mckinney's system
is it is it one year i mean it's one
season i should say
uh as far as hbo is that the commitment
right now
um yeah i think so but i i i think the
plan is to do more than one
okay so um yeah i don't know what the
contractually what it is right now but i
think the plan is to do more than one
you get a cameo
i did get a cameo do you play yourself
in the series
well i would have only been like six
years old at the time but i do play
they let my uh i played um a reporter my
wife catherine
was uh rod thorne's executive assistant
during the draft and my kids
played extras uh during a scene
in a hollywood set so it's been really
cool it's been great
i was also wondering we brought this up
like if you were looking at like kobe
and shaq
that that feels like that would be an
interesting series
i don't know if you right i mean i wrote
a book i wrote a book on the error if
they
i welcome them to options three-ring
circus yeah yeah yeah i have no problem
with that yeah
sure why not i was wondering is there
another
let's say you could pick any other
basketball mclovin do you have a couple
oh i was saying uh you know the lebron
heat team
or maybe the kevin durant and the
warriors recently like a moneyball
version of the warriors
i don't know if there's any real drama
there lebron going back to the cavs
i mean you i heard you guys talking
about it i wrote a book my first book
was about the 86 mets
and that book has been optioned about 73
thousand times
and the mets have always just been a
pain in pain in the butt about it i'm
hoping new ownership maybe but but
i think the 86 match great story
i don't know if we ever crossed paths
but i i was working at cnn
and uh covering the mets back then
and i like there's stories i can't tell
but i mean it was crazy
one time i was in uh chicago i can tell
this and this isn't bad but i see lenny
dykstra
at the china club and lenny has a dip
he's got a cigarette and he's got a
drink
and he had like all the vices well all
the vices i knew of back then
but he had it all going on and uh i i
just remember whenever you were around
these people
they were all they were big pers even
gary carter
you know kid was straight as can be but
he was a big personality then you had
goodin who was private
you know strawberry you're never quite
sure keith hernandez i was never quite
sure
roger mcdowell you know danny heap jesse
like there are all these personalities
here
how did you kind of keep track of you
know who to go to
and who not to go to i just want to say
i just said to someone the other day and
i bet you'd agree with this
if you had said to someone in 1986 which
of these players is going to pass first
gary carter would have been the last guy
in that list yeah it just would have
been the last guy he was a straight
living clean blah blah blah
blah my favorite dijkstra is um they
were at a golf club one time
and there were a bunch of priests in the
golf club i don't know why playing golf
or whatever
and um in the clubhouse and lenny
dykstra goes to a friend
watch this and he walks up to the priest
lifts a leg and just drops a huge fart
in front of the priest like he was the
most vile
but entertaining he'd be a great
character in a movie
i just i think that that team was just
stuffed with characters as you noted but
you had 86 mets 86
new york giants and they only won one
and i kept thinking
both of those underachieved with the
talent that they had
but if you had lt with parcells and the
giants that might have been an
interesting one as well so
you guys agree yeah well good luck with
this jeff congrats it's a great book
it's uh showtime magic kareem riley in
the uh l.a laker dynasty of the 1980s
and uh now it's been green lit by hbo
thank you jeff
all right thanks tim all right